[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Metro Police in morning this is the
procession outside of Sunrise Hospital
this morning carrying the body of
Officer Trung Tai the 49 year old was
shot and killed on duty early this
morning officer Thai served with Metro
Police for 23 years right now the
intersection where that shooting
happened it is still shut down the men
accused of shooting officer Ty is under
arrest and metro police are grappling
with the Second Officer to die in the
line of duty this year this morning's
incident happened after a domestic
disturbance near Flamingo and University
officers were responding and they say 24
year old Tyson Hampton was tracked down
not far away after that initial shooting
a little bit far away from that a Desert
Inn and Eastern this afternoon we have
Team coverage of this Victoria Saha is
near the shooting scene we're going to
start though with Candace Charles who is
at Metro headquarters Candace good
morning
yeah just before seven this morning here
at Metro Police Headquarters Sheriff Joe
Lombardo announced the unfortunate news
that 49 year old officer Chung Tai had
been shot and killed in the line of duty
as the shock sets in the community is
already coming together for its family
our condolences go out to his family
and we will be helping them in any way
we can a somber morning for Metro Police
as they try to come to terms as to what
happened to officer Trung Tai he was
shot on a call about a domestic dispute
this started near Flamingo University
Center Police say shots were exchanged
between 24 year old Tyson Hampton and
officers the incident demonstrates the
dangers our officers face every day
just putting on the uniform and doing
their job officer Tai was hit in the
Torso he was rushed to Sunrise Hospital
where he passed away
[Music]
around six this morning Metro Police
honored officer Ty's Life With A
procession and I always found that he
was something that was willing to help
me learn and I always appreciated that
about him officer Tai served as a metro
police officer since 1999. officer Jesse
Comal Bernstein who was the vice
president of the injured police officers
fund met officer Ty when he first joined
the force now he wants to help officer
Ty's family through this rough time
every time we have an officer that is
injured or unfortunately killed in the
line of duty we always find that our
community stands up and is willing to
help them and their families in any way
they can
yeah sorry Lisa and you can help as well
the injured police officers fund has
already started fundraising money you
can go to our website 8newsnow.com for
that information another person was also
injured in the shooting and treated at
the hospital more details to come for
now reporting from the Metro Police
Headquarters I'm Candace Charles 8 news
now Candace thank you very much nearly
12 hours later as we mentioned the
streets are still closed near the
shooting Victoria Saha live at Flamingo
University Center with reaction from
Witnesses Victoria
John good afternoon to you yeah a huge
part of this area by University Center
Drive is still blocked off as police
investigate this deadly shooting that
took the life of one of their own
however residents in the area say they
are shocked and saddened that this
happened just steps away from their home
police lights and yellow caution tapes
surrounding the point on Flamingo
Apartments Thursday morning residents in
the area say the domestic disturbance
shorted near the complex but it's still
unclear if those involved lived there
however we spoke to Residents who say
they woke up startled from the sounds of
gunshots Jonathan Segovia says he went
outside right away my back window is
right here so we looked out the window
and that's when we seen the option the
brown uniform on the floor I see the
police coming from left to right
and then you have to just turned
gunshots and it was just cops are
swarming everywhere
and then you know what I did hear the
cop yelling I heard the cops screaming
that got shot like just acting like he
was in pain so gobia says he always sees
a large police presence in this
neighborhood but today's news of losing
a police officer in the line of duty was
just another reminder of how dangerous
this area could be
yeah and just within the last minute
actually the westbound part of flamingo
is open up to traffic but you can see
there is still some crime tape up there
Victoria Saha eight news now